elaine maxwell
the business associate paramour and
madam for jeffrey epstein
has just been sentenced to 20 years in
prison but i got to tell you what
something tells me she's not going to
serve her entire term
her entire sentence
no
i i don't think that elaine maxwell is
going to be in prison for 20 years i
think she's probably
i think it's going to be shorter and i
don't think it's going to be shorter
because of parole unless parole is the
new nickname that we're giving to
hillary clinton i don't think so
i think that uh you know you're going to
see a fedex truck pull up
you're going to see some kind of shadowy
figure in a nice purple pant suit
with groucho glasses on and a big thick
mustache
walking in there kind of bulging at the
hips
and then the cameras are going to go out
and then the guards are going to fall
asleep
and then it's just me and you elaine
that's that's that's right it's old hill
dog again
you thought you were through with me
lane i don't think so
uh no hillary no please hillary i'll do
anything that's
no i'm
i'm possibly joking i'm not quite sure
but i don't think she's going to serve
her whole term
they already put her on suicide watch
even though her attorney says she is not
suicidal another psychologist who
examined her said she is not suicidal
that's that's ominous that they would
put her on suicide watch already maybe
she makes it i don't know that she'll be
assassinated or kill herself or whatever
but
the entire
process has been really really weird all
the way
back to the first prosecution and
investigation of jeffrey epstein where
he got this ridiculous sweetheart deal
down in palm beach because the u.s
attorney heard from his higher-ups that
epstein belonged to intelligence that's
the that's the testimony of alex acosta
when he was up for labor secretary but
he had been u.s attorney down there in
florida
then
epstein basically was just checking in
at the at the county jail in palm beach
and then he was going about living his
life perfectly fine
then he finally there was too much of a
media storm he does get arrested and he
winds up dead in prison because just all
those cameras malfunction and the lights
and the guards and whoopsie-daisy what
what can you say that's too bad these
people who have the
uh blackmail the extremist form of
blackmail on
the most powerful people in the world
then all of a sudden you get the arrest
of kelaine maxwell and yet we haven't
seen very much from the trial we haven't
heard very much from the trial and most
importantly we don't know who's in the
book
that's all i care about i don't care if
elaine maxwell serves her sentence i
don't i don't really care about elaine
maxwell at all i don't really care about
jeffrey epstein at all i want to know
about the operation i want to know who
was funding the operation jeffrey
epstein had a lot of money and no one
really seems able to to explain where
the money came from
were there other backers were there
other private backers were there state
backers what does it mean that he
belonged to intelligence that's kind of
weird
and then here's what i really want to
know before elaine puts on the orange
jumpsuit and waits for hillary to come
and knock it
who's in the book
who's in the book
who are the clients
who went who was going to the island
what did they do when did they go how
many times were they on the airplane
that's what i want to know
and yet that's the only information we
can't seem to find and everybody seems
in on it
the federal investigators the
prosecutors
the everybody seemed the media for that
matter
why don't we know who is in that book we
got her we got her she's in the orange
jumpsuit she's just been sentenced
why are they closing the book why is
there some sweetheart deal here that
keeps all of these clients out of the
media spotlight
it it the reason i'm making some jokes
about hillary clinton here the reason
that people are making those jokes and
not jokes is because we don't have any
trust in the elite because this case in
particular and so many others are so
obviously crooked and corrupt that's why
because we don't think that we can
believe the federal government
we don't think that we can believe the
justice system we don't we don't have
any respect for these shadowy elites and
not so shadowy elites fairly public
figures who were shown up to the island
getting weird massages from the little
girls
that's why
and this is what because we don't have
respect for these institutions anymore
because they've squandered their
credibility
we're all expecting elaine maxwell to to
be suicided
how many of you out that you're thinking
right now you're listening to this show
if elaine maxwell turned up dead
tomorrow
one would you be surprised too do you
think she would have killed herself i
bet the majority of people would say
yeah she might turn up dead and no i
don't think it would i think she would
be assassinated
there was the weird death of john mcafee
the eccentric libertarian
uh gazillionaire behind the the software
bearing his own name remember he said
i'm not i'm not suicidal i'm not going
to kill myself people are trying to kill
me i might wind up dead in a prison and
what happened he wound up dead in a
prison
he even had a tattoo that said whacked
jeffrey epstein no one thinks that
jeffrey epstein killed himself very few
people do
why do we think this stuff happens
there have been weird cases there's one
case i don't know if you've seen this
it's gotten a little bit of reporting in
the mainstream media but it's a strange
one the case of michael hastings you
ever hear about this one this was a few
years ago now
michael hastings was a journalist who
was working on some stories about the
deep state about the alphabet letter
agencies and the
secret workings of the federal
government at home and abroad and he
began to think that he was being tracked
and he began to think that he was being
surveilled and he began to think that
people were coming after him
and then he wound up dead of a really
weird car crash
and
this car crash didn't just raise the
eyebrows of the tin foil hat conspiracy
theorist cooks raised the eyebrows of
very well respected and credentialed
national security officials the former
u.s national coordinator for security
infrastructure protection and
counterterrorism richard clark
said that what is known about the crash
is quote consistent with a car cyber
attack he was quoted as saying
there is reason to believe that
intelligence agencies for major powers
including the united states know how to
remotely seize control of a car so if
there were a cyber attack on hastings
car i'm not saying there was i think
whoever did it would probably get away
with it
that's kind of spooky stuff that the
governments could do that and that
people believe that they would have done
that now other people around this
journalist michael hastings said well he
was being erratic he was he had other
problems i don't know maybe he did just
kill himself and maybe he did i don't
know i don't i don't know very much
about this case at all
that that's actually sort of the whether
he was assassinated or not is almost
beside the point
the the
the more important point for all of us
is the erosion of trust that we have in
our established institutions
we think that these these institutions
could do these kinds of things
and so we allow jeffrey epstein died
okay well he didn't kill himself oh
elaine maxwell's on suicide watch here
we go set your clocks here we go
that that speaks to a corrupt elite
an elite that is now
so mired in lies
and
wickedness
and ugliness and all the stuff that we
don't want in society that the society
has become unrecognizable if you enjoyed
that clip from the michael knowles show
and i
i know that you did
i trust that you did check out the rest
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts and most importantly
of all here's what we need we need you
to become a member at the daily wire
okay dailywire.com
knowles you'll get access to a library
of exclusive content you can use code
knowles save 25 on your new membership
today you will help us
fight this fight we have racked up some
pretty big wins here at dw specifically
and on the conservative side uh we can
only do it when you put your money where
our mouths are so we really appreciate
your support right now dailywire.com
knowles save 25 percent
[Music]
[Music]